o latitude pessoal de quem falou dar que
sejam muito bem vindos já é mais um
vídeo e os trabalhos de que carla diz
correntes ou coragem eu acho que é isso
é este é um jogo de tudo o que eu posso
sped mesmo muito obviamente não é esse é
o principal foco aqui do canal este
ambiente é bastante laxante nada
assustador mas dizem que este jogo está
cheio de jogos quer dos anjos diz que
saltam tipo da justiça ai ai ai meus
altos time não vamos ganhar vamos ganhar
ok pessoal só que estamos à espera não
te mexas vamos abrir o caixão
laboratório discreto foi desenvolvido
para a senhora acha que ele causa a
doença
ok pessoal basicamente nós estamos num
laboratório discreto é onde estamos a
desenvolver algo chamavo silom ciro mas
que é isso é basicamente isso vai afetar
o nosso cérebro pelo que eu percebi
fazendo com que vocês tenham medo eu
acho que é isso e nós temos que sair
daqui antes que os iron acho que era
isso é feito o nosso corpo inteiro e
casta o especismo deus trabalhavam para
fazer o círculo ruim do xp ou vista meu
qualquer das formas ambos exibem do som
são muito boas muito bons
ok eu acho que tudo isso vai estar em
cima pois não e texturas e incríveis o
melhor jogo 2015 eva ok pessoal vamos lá
torcida que eu não consigo correr
não consigo ver a e corredores não não
corredores não porque meu pai meu
parceiro que disse eu sei eu saiu cá
estava não melhor textura 2015 também na
porta
o melhor sexto 2015 é é fã de rock muito
bem este jogo não tem nem que eu sempre
quis vestir só por ser um j pele e já
está bem mas eu confesso a tua mãe que
seria assim não tem medo é muito confuso
já dentro um salto gigante e isto tem
muitas portas por isso optado por vir
por aqui pro tem uma cadeira já só que
alguém
é não percebi
não percebi rock vamos avançar o pessoal
não sei por onde é que isto íris parecem
ser um labirinto el k esta sala não tem
nada vamos sair daqui e de que o susto
foi muito poder
ok ela vai ter que tinha o valor eu não
vi que o valor mínimo
isso não tem valor nenhum é que dentro
então estar aqui perto não acorda mané
lugar num cofre meu andar muito devagar
falo porque a música por ou pouca calma
contigo eu tenho está blindada já isso é
o que esse tipo nível culpa doença não
afetou é isso love
estamos no lobby principal era onde
estava antes eu acho para o sexual está
confuso está muito confuso ou não deve
porque eu acho tem tiros cada as
primeiras outras salas meu eu vi ter um
mapa também ontem o mapa não não tenho
mapa eo km não parece uma apanha por
isso não deve ter mesmo um mapa ok eu
vim de onde já não sei de onde eu vim
por isso eu vou escolher uma sala muito
foco em renda fixa o que o laboratório a
chuva não parou após ler amigo o caí
conforto grupo na sala de estar
acho que é isso
ohga né nem esta música é um não tipo
muito foi um pessoal muito funk foi eu
suspeitei que por cima um bis qualquer e
um susto
- vocês não querem assustar deixem
passar tipo mais um pouco à frente por
vítima por ser mesmo a minha frente ao
perceber que não façam isso mel esta
sala não tem nada por isso vamos ver as
outras e vamos lá ver se agora não
conseguem estar bem né ai eu já entrei
aqui daqui a pouco no goleiro não vai
dentro de casas muito bem em pé e alguma
porta não ok eu vou porque mesmo isto
parece o canto de cisne os gastos
hipnotizar que pelo louvar e até a sala
vela depois joão ii e estribo alma e eu
já não sei dizer eu uso e só tornar só
não sei no futuro só andar só tornará
vista parece um susto já que é porque
deus foram já o tempo em que israel se é
é ok nada
nada de nada se o caráter de abreu o
botafogo não tem dinheiro muito mal
feito
vocês só assustam com o sul mas só
entrou muito mal feito
ok vamos lá porque não há nada pois não
somente no que o bicho a porta só porque
sim nevos embaralha vai voltar para trás
qualquer proposta já poderá que caiu não
digo mais que chutassem surge porque
depois jesus também vai perceber que o
outro não é porque treinei eu já sabia
eu sabia porque eu gostei e me foquei em
god jogos de terror pessoal é que a
vacina é calcinha né
lá não chega aqui e eu sabia que eu ia
morrer mesmo lá alguém vai aparecer
agora eu sabia eu sabia eu sabia eu
sabia que parecem ser a porta pronto já
encontrei a programação deste jogo só
chutar só chutar encontrou os corpos
não apenas é previsível a imagem de
santa cruz jogo é previsível mas assusta
mesmo por isso está bem feito é verdade
eu voltar para trás ou assim eu acho que
sim acho que eu tenho que ir em frente
ainda enfrente dar por favor onde as
voltas não é que nunca mais encontrou
duas coisas
viajo no ensaio que eu te encontrar eu
não entrei aqui ainda calma câmeras cama
jebril edson neto chico leite mel
biscoitos e que o espera na outra sala
sério sério este o tipo 80 ou justo
muito antes o susto quando o personagem
tati por dentro do intituto bocado mas é
ok essa sala o que está em causa mas
também vai prosseguir um bicho não ligam
e desligam não é que a primeira que um
bicho não estava nada à espera do visto
é que entrar ali pra apanhar alguma
coisa mas vamos continuar em frente
pessoal
pelos vistos está corrido bem é tá aqui
muito bonita
eu quero eu estou ok left to indo de led
caer desnível da pista importa a euvira
haja sai pronto eu virar e consulta das
coisas que eu quero ver né pessoal vamos
ver o que vamos ver então os jovens e os
11 o workstation essas coisas todas já
não então por aqui
ok eu não tenho entrada que ainda estão
agora resta importa 2016 é outra vez e
1015 até 2016 uol que nessa meta 3 de
meu espetacular até 2017
o psol estuda tímido apesar de estar
aqui algumas coisas mal feitas não é tão
assustador ivan dodig do gol eo piso de
carga caiu no banheiro um cartão pra ver
alguma coisa estaria em frente meu
instrumento mais medo do que nunca de
sangue tal
eu fui o único foi aquela imagem de
remover aquela imagem tipo herói voz era
o vectra ultimate boss também pessoal
tava isso foi bem divertida pesar tarde
um caminho previsível mas é esse pessoal
espero que vocês tenham gostado deste
jogo não esqueçam também de uma
recomendar jogos nos comentários porque
ultimamente tem visto muitos comentários
e já tem uma lista de jogos para fazer
passeios no pé nem mesmo muito é por
isso não deixe de fazer isso só vai ser
uma grande ajuda mesmo para organizar o
conteúdo aqui do canal e é espero que
vocês tenham gostado então lá e que
favorito foi campeã e até a próxima é e
que jogo observa de 2015 meu muito bom
jogo muito bom
o futuro